we start with some breaking news and
German politics the leader of the
governing Christian Democratic Union or
the CDU has said she's stepping down on
a grid cramp Karen Bower known as a KK
had been widely tipped to succeed on
lemarchal when the Chancellor returns
from politics in about 18 months time
her decision to stand down follows the
scandal over the involvement of the
far-right alternative for Germany in a
regional election cramp Karen Bowser
says her move will not affect the
stability of Germany's coalition
government she's just given a press
conference here in Berlin here's some of
what she had to say I will not run for
Chancellor as I have announced I will
accompany the process of finding a
candidate for chancellorship of the CDU
in the future we have passed the
resolution by the governor executive
session on Friday regarding the
situation in Thuringia and as such my
clear position no cooperation whatsoever
with the AFD and Lincoln's the AFD
stance against everything that defines
us every kind of cooperation we have the
AFD will weaken the city and I stand for
a seedy union that does not cooperate
with AFD and clearly stands against us
so that was an a great cramp Karen Bao
speaking a short while ago the Genovese
political correspondent Kate Brady is
with me in the studio Kate what lies
behind it very strong in blunt statesman
by the woman who's known here as a KK
well I think I'm reaching to a certain
degree there's a sense of a of a blame
game going on here she said
Akki should say she said that the
chancellorship and the position as party
leader of the Conservatives in this case
go hand in hand in hands now it's
interesting that of course it was angler
Marco herself the German Chancellor who
separated those two posts back in 2018
and her theory our thinking behind that
was to make way for a
not only as party leader but most likely
eventually as the conservative
Chancellor candidate come the next
elections and so her thinking was to
give someone else in this case a cake a
who was Michals anointed heir to really
make their own mark on the CDU and to
decide what direction the Conservatives
here in Germany want to go in ahead of
the next elections which at the moment
are set to take place and by autumn of
2021 and so there certainly seems to be
a sense of disappointment from akk a
sense that she feels like she's been let
down and of course I think that was also
made clear over the weekend as well when
Angela Merkel during her trip to South
Africa spoke out about this scandal in
Thuringia and made it very clear on her
opinion on this and that it was simply
something that couldn't be undone the
fact that the CDU the Conservatives have
indeed cooperated with the AFD although
that appointment in that controversial
appointment in Thuringia has fallen
through but the fact is that they did
cooperate with the FT and that simply
cannot be undone and by Mackel voicing
her opinion on that that was also a real
blow to akk and I think that was the
first indication that she might indeed
stand down so she's feeling somewhat let
down we'll continue a conversation in
just a moment but let's first take a
look at the tough fear that on a grid
cramp Karen Bower has had as a CDU party
leader it was all smiles to begin with
in December 2018
annaclaire Crump Karen Bower was elected
as Marcos successor a CDU party leader
the former salon state premier was
Merkel's hand-picked heir and firmly set
her sights on one day filling her shoes
as Chancellor her appointment as German
defense minister soon after was a chance
to prove her worth in a high office but
within her first year as CDU party
leader cracks began to show after a
number of gaffes a joke at carnival
mocking gender-neutral bathrooms sparked
opera from germany's LGBTQI community
toilets these are for men who can't yet
decide whether they want to stand or sit
while peeing while just weeks later
akk came under fire again after she
questioned how opinion is manufactured
online following calls from German
vloggers to boycott her party in
European elections her proposals to
create an international security zone in
Syria were also badly received after
Social Democrats said they hadn't been
consulted beforehand
all the while losses for the
Conservatives in regional state
elections added to her load of criticism
but still she vowed to go on we want the
best and the brightest minds in this
party and everyone should get involved
and if someone has a different opinion
from me that's living democracy we can
grow with it and I want this union to
grow to make us stronger than we are
today that's the aspiration that I bring
to this party but it was last week's
scandal in the eastern state of
Thuringia that sowed the final seed of
doubt in a kaykai's authority the
Thuringia arm of the CDU overstep party
line and cooperated with the far-right
AFD to elect the new state premier now
following Crump Karin Bauer's
resignation the conservative CDU is left
with a familiar crisis wondering yet
again who can succeed Angela Merkel and
that report party w's keep really a
political correspondent she's with me in
the studio now kid obviously the CDU is
in a bit of a crisis right now but does
this also mean a crisis in the German
government well for the moment it seems
that everything's stable in the German
government the Social Democrats the
junior coalition party in this so-called
grand coalition have said that they're
very much willing to continue but of
course the personnel debate the
personnel crisis within the CDU could
quickly get out of hand and it depends
now on how that develops in the coming
weeks and coming months we're expecting
to see a new leader of the CDU elected
later this year it could be as early as
summer but we'll have to wait and see
when
next hoard their party conference so for
now it seems that the government at
least is stable and if anything it will
be the Social Democrats today who will
be breathing a sigh of relief that it's
not them for a change that's at the
center of this crisis and get who we
profit from an agreed clamp Karen bars
withdrawal as party leader well
certainly some of the potential
candidates who will be vying to fill her
shoes a CDU party leader they look set
to profit where one name that's already
cropping up quite a lot is Friedrich
mattes a former huge rival of Angela
Merkel who is very keen to finally take
what was snatched away from him a couple
of decades ago and become CDU party
leader and then run for the Chancellery
but if we move away from the CDU as well
it certainly could affect the polls
we've been seen just in the last couple
of days how are the passes have profited
from this scandal in eastern Germany so
certainly other parties especially the
Greens on the one hand you were doing
extremely well compared to the previous
years they'll be looking to try and see
some more of those CD u-boats but at the
same time also the AFD there's a lot of
questions still remain in as to how the
CDU might go in into the next election
try and win back the votes that they
lost lost to the far right aft but
indeed after this debacle that we've
seen and will be continuing to play out
for some weeks and the AFD could still
indeed profit from this as well because
lot of ramifications Katy Perry from DW
s political desk thank you very much for
your analysis we're now joined by
Patrick sense mark is a member of the
German parliament and a member of Anglo
Mackey's CDU party welcome to you now we
heard would a negate cramp Karen bow
said had she lost control over the party
or do you think she feels let down by
her own party executive no I don't think
the party let her down I think she had a
very hard time with elections in our
state's with lots of discussions about
who will be the Chancellor candidate in
the future and I think this is a very
tricky situation for our party we are in
the time when Angela Merkel already said
she steps back as Chancellor and so we
are in the transition period in way and
that was not a very very easy period for
an elite come combo so I think that
altogether was the reason for her to
make this decision today but unequipped
cram canvas movers once again exposed
deep divisions within the party because
after all she was Angela Merkel's
anointed successor but it was a bitter
election campaign for party leader what
impact you think her move now will have
on the governing coalition I think there
will be no problems in the governing
coalition the Coalition is working very
good we have a stable Chancellor we have
our ministers I think as people's
parties on one side the Conservative
Party and the Social Democrats of course
they have discussions with opinion polls
with the elections in the States but on
federal level the Coalition is very
stable and is doing a good work now you
are from the small West German city of
Bree lon and so is one of Annegret
cramped Karen Bowser's main drivers
friedrich Matz who will also be perhaps
contesting for party leadership do you
think he will be the next CDU party
leader I think first of all we're in a
very good position we have more
candidates we have more possible party
members that can follow and a great calm
Karen Bauer
other parties would be happy if they
would have such personal like the CDU
did if it would be a flourish merits
it's not quite sure yet but I think he's
in a very good position he did lots of
work on the basis of the party in the
last weeks and month and I think a lot
of party members trust him having the
capability and the political background
to bring together a conservative group
in the party the Liberals and also the
Christian based groups in the party so
he could integrate and not divide the
party right Patrick's ensberg a member
of Germany's CDU party thank you very
much for talking to us on DW always
welcome